hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Slendy Tilden's 3 you
remember Slendy Tubby's 1 & 2 they were
a multiplayer game okay all right okay
all right okay all right okay I get it I
get it I need to get off the menu just
let me talk to my people okay I remember
that scream because it was a scream that
happened to every single one
[Music]
what I can't control my body I can't
stop dancing
miss ladee dummies you've got me what
the hell is going on this is it this is
nothing like what I was expecting
[Music]
okay hi now Teletubbies were harmed in
the making of this game somehow I doubt
that very very much except Dipsy he
suffered okay that makes more sense
you are you oh oh my playing oh I am why
am i a weird fuzzy Teletubby which one
am i I don't I never watched telescopic
so I have no idea if this is normal oh
hi tinky-winky okay oh oh I want tubby
custard me too let's go inside and get
some okay but you should talk to law law
first she's been upset all day okay then
alright hi Lala how you doing what's got
y'all bothered oh hi PO are you okay no
I had a bad dream last night it was
about us and bad things happened but I
can't remember what oh I think I
remember I think I remember for the both
of us
sounds scary but it was just a dream try
to forget about it yeah I'm sure that'll
be totally fine you want to play I don't
really feel like playing okay goodbye
then be on my way the creepy son baby is
just gonna stare at me for a long time
oh look at the flowers flowers what'd I
do
they are so pretty they're about to not
be probably oh whoa what is that it's an
inventory bar probably okay let's go in
the house and get some custard why not
to get the damn house entrance yes
please that's what I want to do yes it
just looked weird why are they so fuzzy
oh hello hi Dipsy
they didn't say that Dipsy suffered hi
dev z hey have you found your hat yet no
hope it's been missing for so long that
I can't even remember when I lost it
you'll find it eventually I'm sure
do you know how to turn on the custom
machine of course you need to press the
on button on your ride dumbass
ah now I remember thanks okay goodbye oh
if you're making custard make me some
too I'm utterly confuse confused as you
are guys I have no idea what I got
myself into and I have no idea why this
is any of a thing okay make custard oh
[Music]
the machine is broken again I guess I
better fix it goes why not flight choked
to death and died hello
jump rope oh that it was that it still
works but I don't need it right now I'm
sure I'm gonna need it when everything
goes to hell oh that was the inventory
okay now time to fix the custom machine
okay
well there isn't a Teletubby mechanic
that you can call out for huh
are there even any other Teletubbies in
the entire Teletubby world I'll need to
find it okay I got it so I'm not right
that's to do it yeah you did it
copy custard don't mind me I'm creepy
could you please make custard and hand
it out to each of us we're hungry
why don't you get your own custard you
damn bastards I or entirely defective
machine yeah sure I guess I'll make my
own once I made enough for you guys
whatever you lazy bastards okay
oh hi again PO sniff comforter and so
insult grow up Lala I don't want to hear
it now shut up and eat Lala is scared
great this whole thing is scary it's
scary in a totally different way Hill
whoa hey Dipsy hope you suffer Hey oh
yes that's it then I'll just eat my own
serving of this cursed custard that's
going to infect our souls and cause us
to be durable
now they'll inject myself with some
dummy costume ten hours later oh yeah
okay that music sounds incredibly
familiar I know I've heard that many
times before oh I can't sleep
but gusted it's infecting my soul oh hi
okay bye Tinky Winky okay what are you
doing
tinky-winky really loud dots wait where
are you going tell you we can come back
it's dangerous at night for some reason
wake the others
sure I like the others that sounds like
a good idea guys wake up take you with
you broke the custom machine and left
it's not crazy we got to kill him trust
me we just gotta kill him huh what why I
don't know but I'm worried we need to
find them okay get a torque go get it
torch from the workbench and I'll be up
in a minute
sure you will you guys go oh he's gonna
die first
that's why Dipsy suffers okay I know
exactly where the torch is because
Teletubbies is a British show I gotta
pick up the builders torch and take it
out I'm too fine pinky Winky
are they ready ready Oh No
Lala's gone well I guess I'm on my own
for now let's Lala oh there's Lala okay
wala really is up I'm not gonna talk to
you or anything okay let's go find him
hi Lala you came up a little bit close
on me go ahead
dinky Winky where are you
we're very concerned for your safety I'm
not okay I'll go right and look for him
at the lake you go left yes of course
oh is it time to split up and die I
didn't realize that yes we'll cover more
ground or whatever Hey look custard
awesome my favorite kinda
tubby custard how did that get here
tinky-winky doesn't seem to be here I
guess I better check the lake oh you're
not gonna take the custard huh this game
is totally different than what I was
expecting and it's totally different
than what came before it like if they
released this as a full-fledged game out
I wouldn't be high tinky-winky no oh no
what happened - la la reo he's chasing
me I better get to the house quick okay
let me move please wait which way - I
know
Teletubby house god damn it gotta turn
around in the wrong direction and here
we are okay inside inside there we go
Oh No oopsie
Oh No how could this happen something
must have been wrong with the custards
that white tubby is the one oh that's me
wait what Oh
Oh hold what
Oh a quick time effect what I'm gonna do
Oh Oh what did I go upside-down or I did
a tuck and roll okay
ducking popping well I had to turn
around just to check to see if he was
there who kind of idiot would turn
around when something's chasing them I
don't know running for their life let me
just sidestep around you real quick
don't mind me I know you trying to
murder me or whatever I better gather
the remaining custards for research to
find out what went wrong and to prevent
things from getting oh no what I lock
the DOS language what does that even
mean what does any of this mean what the
hell happened what what was even that
what happened
that was the most absurd thing I've ever
played but I loved it why did I love it
well there you go that it was sunny
tummies three the campaign devil I guess
it's a prequel where you know fried five
nights at Freddy's 2 it's a prequel to
the story of what happened before happy
pill god damn idea but I liked it if you
want to play it for yourself maybe
there's an Easter egg that you can find
because holy hell I have no idea what to
do anymore
but either way thank you so much for
watching check out Slendy Tubby's 1 & 2
in the description or in the invitations
over there and as always stop farting I
will see you
in the next locked on target
[Music]